عندما يتعلق الأمر بالوجبات الخفيفة في وقت متأخر من الليل ، فكل
مكان يذهب إليه في اليابان ، فأنت تريد
أن تنغمس في صينية مليئة بتاكو.
تعلم أكي كرات الأخطبوط المشوية باللغة الإنجليزية ، هذه
القصة الكبيرة التي أصبحت ممكنة بفضل شركة
Suntory Japan التي تحب
المأكولات البحرية تمامًا والأخطبوط هو الأخطبوط.  لا استثناء عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالسلطة في تاكوياكي ،
لا تنظر إلى أبعد من غاندا كو ،
سلسلة المطاعم هي أكبر مورد
للطبق مع أكثر من 500 موقع
- ألست خائفًا من إرهاق ماس ماس
في كتاب أكوستا ، يأتي
هذا الأمر.  من الممنوح إلى رئيسنا الأصلي الذي لا
يأكل
صانع تاكو على الإطلاق ، هل
يمكن أن يكون الأمر عبارة عن
نقرة كيانا ، يمكن أن يتبنى كيكوتشيو الموحِّد نقل الحركة الجسدية
بين ORD ، قل ما
الذي تتحدث عنه طائر الدودو Coquina الذي تعرفه نوعًا من الكتلة الحيوية أكبر من
الطحالب
يُقال إن الوجبة الخفيفة نشأت
في منتصف الثلاثينيات من القرن الماضي كطعام شائع شهير
في مدينة أوساكا الساحلية منذ ذلك
الحين وأصبحت وجهة مفضلة في جميع أنحاء
اليابان ومشاهدة طاه تاكوياكي يصنع هذه
pe  كرات rfect هي متعة في حد ذاتها ، لكن
الوذمة المعدنية اليابانية
senato taco Tengiz Denisova Mikio nojima
muy comida además de que esto que
Aspo Matano يقول قائد
مساعدتي ، أي زبون ، Takeyama Terra
، حصل على القطن أي أكثر شهرة ،
لا السالسا الجديد ، كل Morioka مشهور على
الإطلاق  يمكن لـ bougie تقريبًا أن يقول هذا
[الموسيقى]
عموديًا ، فهذه المقاربتان في ملاحظة
a tango kunitake يحمل خنزيرًا يشوي ديكًا
روميًا في تاكو.
تحت الكسافا شاهد هذا التجويف
الديك الرومي أو عمود يريد دونا ديماس
[موسيقى]